shark sightings along the California
coast seem to be scaring people away
from the shore we've been reporting an
increase in sightings there are now been
127 confirmed since May many of them
happened along a 40 mile stretch of
beaches in Orange County Jamie yuccas is
in San Clemente where businesses are
worried that this will hurt their summer
business Jamie good morning good morning
Jeff this is the first week of summer
here and that usually means parents are
dropping off their kids to surf camps or
the Junior Lifeguard programs but with
so many great white sharks spotted just
offshore some as big as 12 feet
businesses report numbers are down even
with the surf up sun-shining
waves ready to ride and this year sharks
lurking offshore after dozens of
sightings local businesses are feeling
what some are calling the shark effect
for surf camp owner John Pierce this is
his lowest attendance in 16 years know
me here we have like 20-plus kids in a
class and I'd run two classes a day can
we be full all summer we waitlists his
business is down more than 50 percent
some surf camps are canceling classes
entirely from board rentals to Junior
Lifeguard programs fewer are willing to
get in the water
what would typically happen is a mom
would say I'm so sorry GP I talked to my
husband and it's just that one chance
they're just nervous
Candice Lazar is one of those moms since
May her family witnessed shark sightings
and beach closings that's why at the
last minute she decided daughter Sloan
would set camp out you have to live your
life so it's hard it's hard to kind of
figure out how to react because you
don't want to overreact there's that
chance yes there is and that does weigh
on your mind yeah what if I put my kid
in the surf camp and something happens
like you can't forgive yourself oh my
gosh never you would never forgive
yourself and
I think that's why I took the step when
I did there was just so many reports one
right after the other and it was just
getting out of hand it was crazy
within the last year alone two shark
attacks took place within a 25 mile
stretch of Southern California beaches
on April 29th a 36 year old mom lost
part of her right leg she remains
hospitalized lifeguards now begin each
morning scanning the water for sharks
the area is shark free and junior guards
will go on as scheduled for the day San
Clemente lifeguard chief bill Humphrey
says the Predators impact crowds the
bigger picture is there's far more
sharks than it's ever been in this area
it's an anomaly right now 11 year old
Ava McGovern had to convince her mom to
let her trained as a Junior Lifeguard in
a group but even she doesn't want to
hang in the ocean alone a little scared
of the shark do you usually sir I did
sir but now I'm not quite sure if I'm
going to surf like for a long time now
because the shirt that shark affects
sunk a local surfing competition for
kids that was scheduled for later this
month and while there are no concrete
numbers just yet the beach is surrounded
by ice cream parlors surf shops and
restaurants who all are reporting fewer
customers this summer so far gale all
right Thank You Jaime is it hard for jet
to sea of sharks during he's not in
there charlie
if you think a white shirt out there
Orange County you're the expert thank
you